hammer der woche im sächsischen radeberg
baut die stadt diese neue brücke über
die röder
doch die alte völlig marode brücke darf
nicht einfach verschwinden denn sie ist
denkmalgeschützt
also muss das bauwerk stein für stein
abgetragen und dann neben dem fluss
wieder aufgebaut werden so die kuriose
entscheidung der obersten
denkmalschützer des freistaates fast
200.000 euro für eine sinnlose brücke
totalen quatsch also entweder schließt
wasser durch oder ich brauchte keine
brücke also blödsinn denkmalschutz
prinzipiell finde ich schon wichtig aber
es muss halt irgendwo oben sind haben
die mittel die dafür verwendet werden
dies soll nur sachgemäß verwendet werden
dass er hoch und nutzen bringen und
nicht wie dort die brücke eben längst im
zum fluss gebaut wird dass es eigentlich
unnötig
immer wieder kommt es im hinterteil zu
dramatischen hochwasser situationen
der grund der durchlass unter der alten
brücke ist viel zu eng deshalb stauen
sich hier die wassermassen das letzte
hochwasser gibt ihr schließlich den rest
die brücke wird so stark beschädigt dass
die stadt eine neue bauen muss doch um
das historische brückenbauwerk entbrennt
ein streit zwischen den
denkmalschutzbehörden von kreis und land
die einen sind für abriss die anderen
für erhalt ergebnis ist ein
abenteuerlicher kompromiss die
naturstein brücke wird abgebaut und aufs
trockene gesetz damit sie aber nicht
komplett nutzlos ist wird extra wasser
unter die brücke geleitet die jetzt im
übrigen auch noch völlig anders aussieht
früher haben es nur noch gemacht wurden
sollen wir das ganze nicht ganz
unglücklich in der gegend rum steht von
der verantwortlichen landesdirektion
sachsen will sich niemand vor der kamera
äußern
schriftlich steht man jedoch felsenfest
zu der seltsamen entscheidung solcher
versetzungen von denkmalen sind in
ausnahmefällen möglich voraussetzung ist
dass das kulturdenkmal seinen
historischen bestand bewahrt und mit der
umgebung verbunden bleibt ausbaden muss
man die versetzung der brücke im
radeberger rathaus der bürgermeister ist
bedient normalerweise dort von der
brücke übers wasser jetzt haben wir die
brücke dastehen und mussten das wasser
anschließend darunter leiden wenn wir
selbst hätten entscheiden können müsste
ich bessere möglichkeiten das geld
auszugeben unglaublich aber wahr ins
hinterteil kommen jetzt schon die
touristen die erinnerungsfotos davon
machen wie hier steuergeld verschwendet
wurde